F is a finite function whose domain is
the letters A to E the following table
lists the output for each input and F's
domain so if X is equal to a then so if
we input a into our function then we
output negative six f of a is negative
six we input B we get three we input C
we get negative 6 we input D we get two
we input Y we get negative six build the
mapping diagram for F by dragging the
endpoints of the segments in the graph
below so that they pair each domain
element with its correct range element
then determine if f is invertible all
right so let's see what's going on over
here let me scroll down a little bit
more so in this purple oval this is
representing the domain of our function
f and this is the range so the function
is going to if you give it a member of
the domain it's going to map from that
member of domain to a member of the
range so for example you input a into
the function it goes to negative six so
a goes to negative six so I drag that
right over there B goes to three B goes
to three C goes to negative six so it's
already interesting that we have
multiple values that point to negative
six so this is OK for F to be a function
but we'll see it might make it a little
bit tricky for F to be invertible so
let's see d is points to two or maps to
2 so you input D into our function
you're going to output 2 and then
finally e maps to negative 6 as well a
maps to negative 6 as well so that's a
visualization of how this function f
maps from a through e to members of the
range but also ask ourselves is this
function invertible and i already hinted
at it a little bit well in order for it
to be invertible you need a you need a
function that could take go from each of
these points to that can do the inverse
mapping but it has to be a function so
if you input 3 into this inverse
function it should give you B if you
input 2 into this inverse function it
should output D if you input negative 6
into this into this inverse function
well
hypothetical inverse function what
should it do well you can't have a
function that if you input one if you
input a number it could have three
possible values a C or E you can only
map to one value so there isn't you
actually can't set up an inverse
function that does this because it
wouldn't be a function you can't go from
input negative six into that inverse
function and get three different values
so this is not invertible let's do
another example so here so this is same
drill we have our members of our domain
members of our range we can build our
mapping diagram a maps to negative 36 B
maps to 9 C maps to negative 4 D maps to
49 and then finally e map to 25 e maps
to 25 now is this function invertible
well let's think about it the inverse
whoops
the was a d maps to 49 a so let's think
about what the inverse this hypothetical
inverse function would have to do it
would have to take each of these members
of the range and do the inverse mapping
so if we input 49 into our inverse
function it should give you d input 25
you should give you e input 9 it gives
you B you input negative 4 and then put
C you input negative 36 it gives you a
so you can easily construct an inverse
function here so this is very much this
is very much invertible one way to think
about it is these are a this is this is
a one-to-one mapping each of each of the
members of the domain correspond to a
unique member of the range you don't
have two members of the domain pointing
to the same member of the range anyway
hopefully you found that interesting